where i want to go to is back to this
line like this is just a specific
version
of this okay so we actually need to go
back a teeny bit further
to this guy right i don't just want to
somehow i don't want it when the angles
are the same i would like to try and
understand
what if the angles were different what
if i had a distinct a
and b so i want you to think for a
moment
hmm i want you to think for a moment and
see if you could work out for me
just like see how we did this right
we're like oh i want this
and i can see it's quite close to here
right so i'm like i can i can sneak it
into there
how could we try and sneak this guy
into here where would i find it where's
the most natural place
to stick that any takers
magicians what are you reckoning into
into x
right like it's sort of like what i did
before there's an argument in here that
is the most
obvious place to put an angle because
it's the only angle i have in the whole
place okay
so what i'm going to suggest you do with
me uh
yeah i think we can keep on going
underneath this right if we were to put
in
a plus b into whaler's formula so i'm
going to say by euler's formula
right
see how i'm building on these results
that i've used before okay i'm going to
put a plus b
into everywhere that i see this angle x
right so to start with what's on the
left hand side it's e
to the power of i this will be a plus b
i'm substituting that in
to my angle like so okay and then on the
right hand side i'm going to do the same
thing so i get
cos of a plus b plus
i sine of a plus b
okay pause for a moment now at this
point here
you're like um i don't know what to do
because
when i got to this line on the left hand
side you're like oh squaring i know how
to square stuff there's it's some
binomial in there a messy binomial but i
can do it
and then we got this result and you're
like cool i'm home we didn't have to do
much work at all
on this slide's a little bit different
there's nothing obvious
to be expanded here right um i mean i
suppose you could expand these because
you know what they're equal to but we're
trying to prove that result we're trying
to prove that so we're trying to imagine
that i don't know what these are equal
to
can i found find out what they're equal
to for manipulating this
now i want you to think right there
really isn't very much we can do is
there anything
that we could any action we could take
on this left-hand side which would be a
simpler way to write it than how it's
written right now
any takers what do you reckon fred oh
that's a good place that your brain is
gone you got like powers right and
you're like oh
this thing is gross i don't want to do
with this taking logs of both sides is
generally a really really good strategy
we use it all all the time in calculus
just when we're hearing arithmetic
i'm going to hit pause on that answer
though just because i already know where
it's going to go on the right hand side
you take logs on the left
you have to hit logs on the right and
you're like ah
gross i'd rather not go there but it is
important that our brain tries it first
i'm only just going to for the sake of
saving our time let you know it's
going to become an unmitigated disaster
so let's hit pause on that idea
any other ideas about what we could do
over here manual split
this one into two eye
so hold on so i'm hearing you i'm
hearing you expand out here right
yes sorry yeah you're just reading a
different um bass okay so i've got a
base of e
right and then up in here there's like
brackets
i can expand them so i'm going to write
it like so which you might think
doesn't do very much to the left hand
side um
i'm going to leave that on the right
hand side but but this here
like think back to when i first learned
index laws right
we're more used to doing this in reverse
direction so if i said uh
because you love the number two if i
said to you two cubed times to the power
of seven
right this is like a typical question
you would get and you'd say oh i know
what to do with these index laws
same base multiplying together what
happens to the indices
you're adam right so this is and you
know what three plus seven is but i'm
going to write it
in that form three plus seven now what
you've got at the moment is not this
to get to here we're kind of over here
so i can actually go the other way
everything you can simplify you can undo
so how would i write this taking
advantage of this knowledge this index
law
it's two things that both have a base of
e right
one will be i a and the other one will
be i
b again i'm actually not going to do
anything to my right hand side here
now the reason why this is useful is
because i actually know what these
things
are in terms of trigonometric functions
right this i can go back to i can use
euler's formula
again right in fact i'm going to because
i'm not writing this uh
right hand side i'm just going to write
the left hand side
according to euler's formula this guy
here
is going to be take a breath
cos of a plus i sine of a do you agree
with that
like it's just my angle is called a
instead of called x right so i'm just
using euler's formula again
and then i've got another complex number
it's going to be cos of b this time plus
i sine of b now
take a breath you guys can take over
just like at this point here you're like
oh it's algebra time
i can square stuff out it comes right
you've got exactly the same thing here
looks a little bit messier but i hope
you're going to be able to get to this
result have a go
and then also see what else you can get
from it not just sign a plus b there'll
be something else that comes for free
just like before okay off you go so
here's one i prepared earlier um
and it's there because number one i
wrote it more neatly and number two
because i'm drastically running out of
space on this board
okay but you can see i hope like most of
the logic that we just did is is on here
anyway
um what have we done here right we've
taken advantage of the fact
that when we have euler's formula we're
looking at the same object from two
angles right do you remember that right
it's like oh i can multiply this whole
thing by a power
or i can separate out the angles
underneath that's that's what we get
from this
okay like you saw before we got
uh the double angle result for sine and
the double angle result for
cos like like that at the same time and
the same thing happens here sine a plus
b
comes in when you compare the imaginary
parts and
cos a plus b just comes along for the
ride when you compare
the real parts and i just find that
lovely now when i was at uni
before i set you on the exercise um we
had to do not just like
learning how to teach mathematics for at
a high school level we actually learned
like what we call undergraduate level
mathematics as well which made my head
spin but one of the things that i always
found so confusing was
when mathematicians wrote papers they
would get to some results
like uh like here right and they would
say
this result is very powerful and i was
like what are you talking about like
powerful like
maybe it's interesting but powerful
seems like a weird word to choose
and i now come to realize what they
meant right
um something like say euler's formula
right it has
power because it gets to other things
really quickly and really
elegantly like you get extra things just
like you didn't even mean to prove this
and it came out it just sort of popped
out as a corollary as the way we would
say it okay
so i hope you've got that down i hope
this is an argument for you if you don't
already do this
to use colors in your working out
because it is immensely helpful not
necessarily for us but mainly for you so
you can sift out
in this algebra suit and when you open
up to exercise 3b which you're welcome
to do now
you're going to see this is going to
happen to you a fair bit there's going
gonna be so many terms
part of the challenge is to sift out
which are the important ones and which
ones are relevant to what you're trying
to solve okay